he is now entering his 11th year in the
NFL out of the you he's Greg Olson of
the Carolina Panthers how you doing Greg
bill well rich always good to be on me
okay so now I got to start with this
first we had Khalil on the day of the
video of Cam Newton's birthday being
mocked and sent up by you guys on your
fishing and camping trip and it looked
like you're playing the role of cam Greg
is that true you're playing the role of
cam in this video I welcome how I got a
I got talked into playing the camera as
the rapper and the okay Taryn if you saw
both videos I don't know if I quite did
as well as he did his look a little
cooler than mine well I mean your hand
gestures looked a little bit more
awkward let's put it that way on there
yeah now were you channeling your inner
Cameron I mean how did you play this
role how did you approach the role Greg
yeah I guess he was my inspiration and
let's be honest when we all saw his
original video we were all jealous I
know a lot of the guys on the team were
it that wherever he was looked pretty
pretty incredible and then there we
found ourselves in the middle of North
Carolina mountains camping it wasn't
quite as glamorous so we we made our
campfire into our rap video set and
turned on some headlights of some pickup
trucks and we did the best that we had
showered in two days and that was the
result
how did camp take it Greg he took it
great he thought it was awesome he I
think he appreciated how much time and
energy in khalil and the rest of us took
trying to accurately recreate his video
I mean if you when you see the two of
them side-by-side it's incredible how
Khalil was able to replicate the
different scenes and that wasn't by
accident that took a lot of effort and
attention to detail but he was a he's a
good sport the guys had a good time with
it you know they say imitation is the
biggest form of flattery so we were
jealous of his video so we had to make
our own well I got to be honest with you
I mean in all seriousness the fact that
you guys did it and Khalil told us how
it got revealed in a Ron Rivera
PowerPoint in front of the whole crew I
think does speak volumes of the fact
that if you thought
kamme wouldn't be into it or he didn't
have a sense of humor you might not have
attempted it in the first place am I
correct in saying that Gregg oh
absolutely I mean we never would have
done it if we thought we were going to
offend them or if he was going to take
it the right way but knowing cam as long
as we had and just knowing his
personality and his willingness to go
along with the fun and be a part of it
like everybody else
it'll make doing those things a little
bit easier you know you're not you're
not quite as hesitant and he took it I
mean the way Ron set it up he kind of
came hard at everybody about you know
making sure we pay attention to what's
put on social media he kind of came off
a little a little aggressive I think
some of the guys in the room were kind
of looking around like who is he talking
to me like what happened I hope he tells
us what happens and then he kind of
yells at the guys turn the video off
turn it on this is what I'm talking
about
and I think after the first two seconds
people kind of got the idea that it was
set up and the video played from there
Greg Olson for the Panthers joining me
here on the Rich Eisen show what what do
you guys talk about Jim you talking
about winning championships what are you
what is the topic of discussion as you
get ready for the final mini camp before
training camp Greg yeah I think I think
the offseason is really kind of just
like layers right it the first phase
kind of preps you for Phase two with the
coaches and being on the field and then
you know Phase two then get you ready
for a little more formal you know OTAs
more you know helmets on actual more
football based practice against one
another in a competitive environment and
then you know from there phase three
kind of closes down and then we J are we
got three days in mini camp so it's
really dialed in here this is our last
kind of dress rehearsal before we show
up to Spartanburg from for training camp
you know let's let's win these three
days let's have the best mini camp that
the Panthers can have and you know
knowing that after these three days you
know we're going to all go our separate
ways guys are going to kind of spread
back out do their own thing for a while
and then the next thing we come back
we're you know we're right on the
doorstep of the season and and we're
going to be going full go down and down
the Spartanburg I can't so it kind of
just progresses as the offseason goes on
and kind of
airs on top of itself and you know we're
for three days away from a little bit of
a break and you got to have they'll have
our best three-day mini camp that
weekend for this time of year
well Greg looking back now that you have
a few months removed what did happen to
your conference title defense season to
make it go so awry I think that's kind
of a million-dollar question I think it
was something that we we wrestled with
the entire season I think you know week
by week you know we thought maybe we
found our magic and kind of refound our
formula there for success and then you
know we'd have a letdown the next week
and then and then struggle to find it
again you know for a handful so you know
to go from seventeen to six wins you
know you know it's to be a rocket rocket
scientist to know that that was a huge
letdown for for all involved and you
know I don't think we did a very good
job bouncing back you know as players
and collectively as a team from from the
success we had the prior year and you
know it's going to be kind of the same
type of response this year but just the
opposite you know how quick are we going
to be able to put that bad taste behind
us and and get ready prepare for an oozy
and that's the way the NFL works and
hopefully we do a better job at
answering the bell after the
disappointment is last last year rather
you know rather than how we did it the
year before House Christian McCaffrey
going to change things you think and
that offense
yeah I think he's dynamic and he's a kid
that we all watched a ton you know his
years in college were as dynamic and
talented as anybody in the college game
I think in the way the NFL is moving the
more guys you can get involved that
bring that dynamic ability as ball
carriers as receivers out of the
backfield that you know we've kind of
gone away as the league from you know
everyone just plays one position you see
so many guys that have to be versatile
and you know for a guy like him to come
in and play tailback be able to play
slop be able to come out of the
backfield be able to kind of go empty
and have an essence another slot
receiver who you could also hand the
ball to it just no there's not a lot of
those kind of guys and I think that's
why we felt so high you know high on em
to take them at number eight and we're
anxious he'll join us for the first time
this week at mini camp tomorrow so we're
looking to have them there looking
forward to having a mom
Greg Olson joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show in the video Luke Kuechly was
on that camping trip with you last time
I saw him I was on that Thursday night
game where it was freaking me out where
he started crying as he was getting
carted off and you know I'm just
wondering about his health and his
readiness to continue being as good as
he has been what can you tell me about
Kiki's health Greg okay judging you know
this is as impressive an off season of
you know we work out a lot together
through the off seasons um you know the
last few years and this is as physically
ready image you know as good a shape and
as you know as much physically prepared
as he's been in the years that I've
known and of course you know we all kind
of shared shared those same thoughts
that you had last year rich watching him
get carted off that game against New
Orleans is a scary sight for for any
player let alone you know one of your
one of your leaders and kind of you know
fixtures on the on the team and you know
it's young the unfortunate reality of
the sport that we all play but you know
it you know just seeing Luke and being
in great spirits and working as hard as
he has and not missing a beat with
workouts and training you know I think
he's in a mentally good place where he's
just kind of moved on from that he's not
playing with any hesitation and concern
and just going to go out and play the
way he always has and I think to a
degree we all just hope for the best for
not only him but for everybody what are
you doing with fan chest calm and time
for Father's Day what he got going on
right here yeah it's pretty cool so
obviously a lot of our fathers and men
in our life for huge sports fans so if
you if you go to can chess comm use my
discount code Greg for 10% off
regardless of the team that they're fans
of you can put together a custom box of
all sorts of a pretty cool giveaway and
merchandise stuff for that special
sports fan in your life and send it
right to their house open the box and
just full of stuff with their favorite
teams and I know I bought them for my
dad and I've had them bought by me and
they're they're really interesting and
it's getting pretty cool thing so in the
world of today people order an offline
and one thing is just send right to your
doorstep it's a for sports fans it's
about as good as you get it involves
over 80 officially licensed top brands
and you can use the code Greg
percent off any chest by going to fan
chess calm for more information how did
cam take the news about relaxing
celebration rules depart man I can only
imagine what you've got in store his his
celebrations Roy's you know must watch
TV to begin with so I'm a hunk of
Nations to see how far it gets pushed
not only by him but just throughout the
league you know I'm not typically a big
elebrate er I'm not that's not really my
cup of tea but I think I think we're in
for some entertainment that's for sure
now you were they'd stay talking to the
team about the fact that they're they're
going to start up a play clock but at 40
seconds the minute that a ref signifies
a touchdown and if there is no review
you best get your extra point unit out
there otherwise you might be expending a
timeout to keep it from being a 38-yard
extra pointed tip out no I that's the
first I've heard that that's your hummin
Greg delivering breaking news to NFL
players to a rich that's the that's the
first that I've heard that that's this
is true that their way of making these
not super long choreographed
celebrations is it directly tied to this
well I don't know if it's directly tied
because this was something that was
announced as part of the commissioners
move to try and move the game along
that's part and part of that part of
that is to take fewer commercial break
so in see when let's say you score a
touchdown commercial break
then kickoff commercial break there's
going to be fewer commercial breaks in
the game and also just get this thing
moving and then claim a celebration rule
announcement I don't know if there's any
connection maybe they're unrelated
interesting no but I'm all about that
that's a good implementation okay
there's there's times where you look
just like you said the opposing team
scores you hop off the bench you go down
you're you pick you know you go down to
where the ensuing kickoff will be they
kick an extra point then you're you're
still you're getting warmed up you're
kind of running around get ready then
they do TV timeout come back do a
20-second kickoff that you're not on
you're still standing there on the
sidelines touch back most of the time
yep you sprint out to the huddle only
for the rest to come back out and call
another TV timeout they scored and seven
eight minutes that pass and you haven't
done a thing it's it's and it feels like
30 minute
when you're on the field so I'm glad
they're making those change they are
making those changes before I let you go
I mean again like I said I started this
interview by talking about your your
on-air excellence I mean you're terrific
at it Greg and I'm you know I'm so
clearly you know what it takes to to be
good at it do you think Cutler's got the
chops analogies going in the booth what
do you think about Jay Cutler the
announcer Greg Olson I do I think people
are going to be are going to be
pleasantly surprised I think Jay is much
more charismatic is much more charming
and informative than people may want to
give him credit for and whether that was
by his choice of the way he kind of felt
was his role as a player and you know in
the way he delica media it was kind of
you know his particular way but I think
now that he's kind of removed from the
game has that all kind of added away I
think people that tune into the games
that he's broadcasting are going to find
a guy that is immensely talented and
informative as far as the game of
football I think he's he's charming I
think he has a good sense of humor I
really think people are going to be
pleasantly surprised I think Jay is
gonna is going to be the surprise you
know kind of new burst on the scene
commentator and the X player on the
category so I really think you're going
to do well you know especially initially
well I'm always a guy that's I've been
rooting for him for years there's just
always something where I just wanted to
like them you know and maybe that's what
you're talking about but I'm concerned
that kevin burkhart is going to be
calling a touchdown and then say Jay
what do you think it'll go huh that's it
so that won't have hi I think I think
you're going to be good I'll say Lee
burkhardt's is as good as he gets
Burkhart and I go way back he actually
started his broadcasting chops doing
some of my high school football games in
North Jersey so I've known Kevin for for
a long time and he's obviously very good
at what he does so I think for Jay to be
in a booth with him and Charles Davis
you know two guys that have done it a
long time I think is going to play you
know kind of play into Jay aber for sure
Greg enjoy Father's Day and we'll send
everybody to fan chess comm drop Greg
for 10% off any chest for some good
stuff for Dad thanks for joining
all right thanks for HOA the pleasure
you bet right back at you
our goals in the Carolina pan the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy